oh god now I don't want to be loud
my name is George George ëletís I'm 27
years old I'm the co-owner of counter
logic gaming which is an eSports gaming
company and what we do is essentially we
host a team in a structure similar to
the NBA
so we have our gamers competing on
stages nationally we fill up venues and
we play online
[Music]
so in the early stages I was running
both the team side and also playing on
the team and that was very very
difficult for me which actually led me
to retiring a little earlier than I
would have liked I thought what was best
for the organization was that I filled
the role of an owner and that's what I
became
we've won championships in North America
consecutively and we've also been very
very close to being relegated from the
league and both those were definitely
high highs and amazingly low lows and so
it was a very tumultuous time in eSports
where you could essentially lose your
brand in your team and overnight and we
were one game away from being relegated
but we pulled it out in the end
so I was always drawn to gaming when I
was younger it was always fun to play
against another another person instead
of playing against the what the game
creators made we always have the
benchmark of like another human being
constantly trying to exceed you in five
years I see myself at the top of the
standings with Madison Square Garden and
really taking CLG to the next level in
cementing ourselves
you
[Music]